les boues dessinateur de métier oui vous
êtes couverts de boue je me suis chargé
par un taureau de 1300 kg
je vous offre un emploi permanent au
sein de la rédaction vous parvenez à
capturer la nature du chat peut-être
parce que vous êtes vous même un
marginal en quelque sorte roues je le
fais pour payer les traites et subvenir
aux besoins de mes 5 sera femme est
précoce qui vivent ce montois nous avons
engagé une gouvernance je crois que tu
es la première personne à voir que ce
sont en fait des créatures ridicule
craintive il courageuses
comme nos
miss richardson a une influence
extrêmement positif sur la famille étiez
vous en train de vaincre
y at il matière à rire monsieur win pas
du tout
[Musique]
vous êtes mal tout un univers de chant
ils deviendront bleus et communiqueront
avec nous dans notre langue après vous
devons devenir bleu oui bien sûr
[Musique]
et moi dans ce qui trotte dans ta drôle
de cap h
[Musique]
l'électricité
alors là louis tu m'inquiètes
je sens patients
[Musique]
de l'électricité
monsieur wayne on m'a fait venir chez
vous car rogers carline s'inquiète mort
de santé mais toi te l'a englouti dans
ces saletés de chats et dans un amour il
réfléchit malsain est vouée à l'échec
[Musique]
vous avez réussi à créer des images
aussi enchanteresse
dans une période aussi sombre
je les ignore
surtout n'oubliez pas
quelle que soit l'adversité
quelles que soient les difficultés que
tu rencontres
[Applaudissements]
d'accord je te botter
la mission de la capture et louis
et d'en faire profiter le plus grand
nombre autour de toi
[Musique]